[Música]
y me gustaría empezar lanzando una
pregunta
una pregunta muy sencilla algunos de
vosotros conoce aquel eslogan
publicitario que fue un éxito y triunfo
en los años 90 y que reflejaba de una
manera muy clara cómo era el mundo en
aquel momento de paso de transición
entre el siglo 20 y el siglo 21 me
refiero a un eslogan corto dos palabras
que fueron elegidas como la marca
europea más valorada entonces
connecting people
muchos los recordaréis es increíble como
con solo dos palabras se puede reflejar
algo que tiene que ver con un paso
importante en la evolución humana
porque lo que sucedió entonces es que
los seres humanos rompimos el cordón
umbilical que nos ataba a la pared en
las comunicaciones de larga distancia y
que nos limitaba hasta entonces nos
comunicábamos solo en algunos momentos y
desde algunos lugares a partir de ahí y
gracias a este pequeño aparato todas las
personas pasamos a estar comunicadas en
todo momento y en todo lugar el cambio
es importante es evolutivo pero duró
poco ese es lo ganó y está obsoleto ya
porque a esta tecnología le sucedió la
siguiente y hubo un día en enero de 2007
cuando steve jobs nos anunció un
producto revolucionario que lo cambiaría
todo el que todos llevamos en nuestros
bolsillos el smartphone que realmente es
un facilitador de la vida digital sobre
todo en el momento en el que da lugar a
un enorme universo de apps de
aplicaciones que nos facilitan la vida y
van cambiando el mundo
y cómo es este nuevo mundo que está
surgiendo a mí me gustaría distinguir o
destacar tres rasgos que definen nuestro
nuevo mundo el primero es un mundo en
cambio' cambio permanente cambio
acelerado cambio exponencial en segundo
lugar hemos entrado en una nueva era es
la era digital en la que muchas de
nuestras creencias valores códigos de
comportamiento se ven alteradas y en
tercer lugar es un mundo hiperconectado
como nunca en la historia hoy tenemos un
nivel de conectividad total entre las
personas y se están empezando a conectar
las cosas el internet de las cosas no
sabemos hasta dónde nos va a llegar es
interesante
y a partir de ahí dos cuestiones más
respecto a este nuevo mundo primera cuál
es el motor que impulsa este nuevo mundo
yo creo que hay pocas dudas el motor es
la tecnología siempre la tecnología ha
sido un impulsor del mundo desde la
invención de la rueda la imprenta la
electricidad pero en este momento lo
está haciendo de una manera más intensa
más sofisticada con un alcance mayor y
la siguiente cuestión cuál es el
escenario de este nuevo mundo
sin duda alguna el escenario es
la ciudad
las ciudades tienen hoy un protagonismo
como no lo han tenido nunca en la
historia de la humanidad las ciudades
están creciendo el porcentaje de
población que habita en ciudades está
creciendo en todo el mundo
cuando hablo de ciudades me refiero a
ciudades pequeñas medianas grandes en
general pero lo cierto es que las
ciudades están de moda en las ciudades
están pasando cosas la ciudad es el
lugar donde todo sucede y el ser humano
se ha convertido en un ser urbano
y qué sucede cuando super ponemos estos
dos conceptos tecnología y ciudad pues
lo que ocurre es que da lugar a un
enorme campo de actividad un enorme
campo de oportunidades y de desarrollo
que muchas empresas han detectado y
están desarrollando soluciones bajo la
marca smart city que ese smart city la
aplicación de inteligencia artificial a
las ciudades la aplicación de soluciones
basadas en la tecnología al desarrollo
de las ciudades y está bien es un
concepto positivo pero posiblemente
podemos ir un paso más allá porque hay
una cosa que creo que no debemos olvidar
y es que las ciudades tienen alma no
sólo tecnología una ciudad tiene alma
que significa que una ciudad tiene alma
a mí me gusta sintetizar lo en tres
rasgos que tienen que ver con el pasado
presente y futuro respecto al pasado una
ciudad con alma es aquella que es
consciente de su identidad ha heredado
una identidad y la utiliza en el
presente para ponerla en valor
vive pervive su identidad la cuida
respecto al presente es una ciudad que
pone el foco en las personas para todos
los proyectos desarrollo planificación
etcétera lo importante las personas y en
tercer lugar respecto al futuro son
ciudades con proyecto ciudades que
tienen una visión y que tiene luego las
herramientas para llevar esa visión a la
acción
bien
pero volvamos a la idea inicial estamos
ya en un mundo en el que las personas
estamos conectadas ahora estamos en
proceso de conectar las cosas y dentro
de las cosas toca también conectar la
cosa con ellas la cosa más grande más
sofisticada y más compleja que el ser
humano ha creado la ciudad por lo tanto
las ciudades también se están conectando
unas con otras y esto es algo que genera
enormes oportunidades y beneficios para
la población para la sociedad para los
que allí vivimos especialmente si nos
referimos a las ciudades de tamaño medio
aquellas en las que vivimos la mayor
parte de nosotros tamaño medio se
consideran las ciudades entre 50.000
habitantes y un millón es decir esas
ciudades tienen muchas ventajas del
hecho obtienen muchas ventajas del hecho
de conectarse con ciudades próximas y
trabajar en claves de cooperación bien
estas ideas las ha desarrollado con
intensidad algunos pensadores por
ejemplo recientemente para astaná ha
publicado un libro en el que desarrolla
estos conceptos
el concepto de la conecto grafía
en mi caso he dedicado mi vida
profesional a trabajar sobre ciudades y
territorios a contribuir a la
transformación de ciudades y de
territorios y en ese sentido pues
acumuló ya una cierta experiencia en los
últimos 25 años con los equipos de la
fundación metrópoli hemos desarrollado
planes y proyectos que tienen que ver
con estos conceptos conceptos
relacionados con redes de ciudades
ciudades conectadas ciudades que se unen
a otras y se planifican conjuntamente
para de esa manera ser más fuertes más
competitivos en el contexto
internacional y ofrecer más calidad de
vida a las personas que la habitan
hoy vamos a compartir dos ejemplos que
tienen que ver con esta forma de
entender las ciudades ubicados a 8.000
kilómetros de distancia uno del otro en
torno al océano atlántico mirando a dos
mares el cantábrico y el caribe en dos
continentes europa y américa en dos
momentos históricos siglo 20 y 21 pero
en ambos casos con un rasgo en común y
es proyectos que buscan el desarrollo de
la sociedad el primero de ellos se puso
en marcha en los años 90 aquí en bilbao
en el país vasco'
yo nací cerca de aquí y viví aquí en mi
infancia a pocos minutos de bilbao y
recuerdo como recordaréis muchos de
vosotros cómo era la vida en los años
80-90 era una etapa difícil había
problemas había declive económico
violencia terrorista todo tipo de
problemas ambientales degradación
ambiental de naturaleza etcétera y una
sensación extendida de desánimo de
preocupación hacia el futuro
esta imagen refleja este lugar en el que
estamos y este lugar se transformó donde
se construían barcos hoy se construyen
ideas hoy se construye talento hoy se
construye interacción entre las personas
y al igual que se transformó este lugar
se transformaron otros en un esfuerzo
colectivo que en dos décadas cambio la
ciudad de bilbao y la llevó a otro plano
la llevó a otra situación
afortunadamente
el icono de la transformación es el
museo guggenheim que precisamente acaba
de cumplir 20 años pero a mí me gustaría
poner el énfasis en algo que también
cumplió 20 años hace poco y es la
estrategia territorial vasca a la vez
que se inauguraba el museo se aprobaba
esa estrategia que está a día de hoy
todavía vigente y que ha contribuido a
generar un cambio en el territorio vasco
un desarrollo una transformación
positiva
una transformación positiva basada en la
definición de un nuevo modelo
territorial porque porque las ciudades y
los territorios se transforman son entes
vivos son entes que tienen momentos en
su vida momentos buenos momentos malos
momentos regulares por lo tanto este
territorio se ha transformado a partir
de una visión de la visión de un modelo
territorial al igual que lo ha hecho la
villa de bilbao
el país vasco se concibe en esta
estrategia territorial como un modelo
policéntrico en el que las tres ciudades
capitales es decir tres ciudades medias
bilbao donostia-san sebastián y vitoria
gasteiz se articulan según criterios de
cooperación y complementariedad entre
ellas no competencia interna para así
dar lugar a un ecosistema de innovación
y calidad de vida que integra también y
favorece las ciudades menores los
pueblos los espacios naturales los
espacios productivos el litoral y todo
ello a partir de un modelo de
conectividad pasado en un sistema sólido
y robusto de infraestructuras carreteras
puertos aeropuertos y de manera singular
un sistema ferroviario que en su momento
se planteó como un sueño que hoy ya está
en una avanzada fase de construcción y
pronto será una realidad
este sistema de alta velocidad
ferroviaria va a permitir dos cosas por
una parte la conectividad de larga
distancia con madrid o con parís pero
por otro lado muy importante la
conectividad interna de la ciudad región
el metro de la ciudad región las tres
capitales se pondrán a media hora de
distancia una de la otra y eso es
importante cuando yo era niño hace hace
poco sancious
pues plantear un viaje entre las
capitales vascas era preparar un viaje
había que hacer la maleta hoy la
conectividad es fluida el sajjil es
cotidiana y dentro de poco va a ser
mucho más natural cómo moverse en metro
por una ciudad región
esto es importante esto genera
desarrollo genera progreso y genera
bienestar para la sociedad bien a partir
de aquí volvemos al presente y hacemos
un viaje al caribe nos vamos a conocer
el otro ejemplo que os quería compartir
que es el proyecto diamante caribe en
colombia con liderazgo por el gobierno
nacional los gobiernos de 10 provincias
y los 11 alcaldes de las ciudades
principales como cartagena barranquilla
bucaramanga santa marta etcétera y con
un esfuerzo de innovación social en el
que dimos entrada a líderes de distintos
colectivos de esas ciudades para
territorios para que manifestaran su
opinión este proyecto se desarrolló
recientemente sobre un territorio
maravilloso donde viven 14 millones de
personas
en el que hay enormes oportunidades
biodiversidad etcétera pero también hay
graves problemas problemas que a veces
tienen que ver con la falta de
desarrollo y falta de conectividad el
proyecto nació en el momento en el que
el gobierno comenzaba a preparar los
acuerdos de paz con la guerrilla en
consecuencia ellos vieron que era llevar
desarrollo a los territorios más
olvidados es un prerrequisito para
alcanzar una paz estable y duradera
enseguida nos dimos cuenta de que el
acceso a ciertos lugares era complicado
carreteras sin asfaltar avionetas canoas
etcétera y llegamos a dos conclusiones
que son extrapolables a otros lugares
también primero que las áreas de mayor
desarrollo son las áreas donde están las
ciudades y el ámbito directo
la influencia urbana esto es muy
importante y segundo más dramático que
las áreas de pobreza extrema son
aquellas áreas donde anida la violencia
y aquellas son precisamente las que
tienen un déficit de conectividad
las que están mal conectadas con las
ciudades y con el resto del territorio
conclusión hay que atacar ese tema de
lleno es importante por eso el proyecto
propone un centenar de acciones
dirigidas a mejorar fomentar el
desarrollo de esas ciudades y
especialmente la conectividad entre
ellas y de los territorios olvidados en
beneficio del desarrollo social de toda
la población y como no podía ser de otra
manera en este caso dada la época en la
que estamos viviendo en este proyecto
además de las cuatro infraestructuras
clásicas de conectividad carreteras
ferrocarriles puertos y aeropuertos se
aborda también una quinta que es la
infraestructura de conectividad digital
y las tecnologías digitales de la nube
todo lo que es el mundo nos aporta real
realizando por primera vez una
convergencia entre la planificación
física y la planificación digital al
servicio del desarrollo de la sociedad y
para terminar me gustaría lanzar una
reflexión en qué nos afecta todo esto de
nuestra conectividad a nuestra vida
diaria
pues hay una cuestión clara muchos
estudios han demostrado que la conexión
social genera bienestar salud e incluso
longevidad
y eso nos lleva llegando al campo de las
ciudades a pensar que más allá de las
megalópolis sin alma de escala inhumana
que a veces a veces parece que están
llamadas a liderar el mundo existe un
enorme espacio de oportunidad para las
ciudades medias siempre que estén
conectadas formando redes y de esa
manera sumen sus activos unas con otras
el territorio vasco ha hecho ese
esfuerzo en las dos últimas décadas y ha
logrado una transformación positiva
modélica el caribe colombiano está
lanzándose ahora en este proceso y
también está aspirando a definir un
modelo territorial de progreso y futuro
pues a partir de ahí y volviendo a la
idea inicial mi conclusión es muy clara
tenemos suerte de estar viviendo este
momento como decíamos al principio hace
20 años el reto era conectarse las
personas y ese reto se logró hoy estamos
en un mundo diferente en el que se está
construyendo un mundo
hiper conectado con una conectividad que
afecta a todas las cosas y entre ellas
también a las ciudades el lugar donde se
produce la vida en comunidad y el
encuentro entre las personas por eso es
interesante y es inteligente apreciar
los valores de las ciudades medias
conectadas conectadas en red conectadas
entre sí conectadas con el mundo para de
esa manera aprovechar y sacar todo el
partido a este mundo de nueva
conectividad que la sociedad actual nos
aporta y que se puede y se debe poner al
servicio de la calidad de vida de las
personas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]